Let's now consider how
to find the velocity
of the center of mass of a wheel
that's rolling without slipping
down an inclined plane.
So let's draw a picture.
Here is the wheel that
starts at t equals 0.
And this is an angle phi.
And at some later time
t final, the wheel
has dropped a distance h
along the incline plane.
And now let's figure
out what is the velocity
of the center of
mass of the wheel
when it gets to the bottom.
And we're now going to
apply our energy arguments.
Now the first thing we have to
realize is a very subtle point
here is that there
can be friction.
And we saw that when a wheel
is rolling without slipping,
there can be static
friction at the contact
point between the
wheel and the ground.
There is a gravitational force.
And a normal force.
Now static friction does no
work because the point is always
instantaneously at
rest and f dot ds is 0
because the object is at rest.
And so the ds is 0.
So our static
friction does no work.
And therefore, from
our energy principle
that the external work equals
E final minus E initial,
we have no external work and
so our energy is constant.
Now how do we
analyze our energy?
Well, I've set things up.
So I'm going to choose my
potential energy to be 0
when it's at the bottom.
And that our initial energy is
only equal to potential energy.
If the wheel has a mass m,
gravitational force down,
the potential energy
initially is mgh.
The final energy is
only kinetic energy.
The wheel is rolling
with omega final.
Its center of mass is moving
with v center of mass final.
And we just saw that
the kinetic energy
has two contributions; the
translational kinetic energy,
1/2 m--
we'll just call
this final squared.
And we'll make that the
final just to make it easier.
And it has the kinetic
energy of rotation.
Now the rolling without
slipping condition
is that the translational
center of mass speed
is equal to the
radius of the wheel,
r, times the angular
speed, omega final.
So I can write E final
as 1/2 of m plus I
cm over r squared times the
final squared, where I'm just
replacing omega final
equals v final over r.
And therefore, that the kinetic
energy by the energy principle
tells us that E
initial equals E final.
So mgh equals 1/2
times m plus I cn
over r squared v final square.
So we can find that v final is
equal to the square root of 2
mgh divided by m
plus 1/2 cm r square.
And that is the final
speed of the center
of mass translational's
velocity of the wheel
as it dropped a height h.